on immigration now that was the sleeper
issue of the 2016 election no one in
power on either side wanted to talk
about it but voters did the newer
immigration policy was not serving their
interests and that's why Donald Trump
won you think both parties would have
learned something from that experience
kind of a big deal and the message is
clear voters don't want open borders and
they've said so emphatically but
Congress is still not even pretending to
listen many Republican members on the
hill are still pushing for a mass
amnesty under the Orwellian title of
comprehensive immigration reform and
Democrats well they've gone completely
off the deep end twenty years ago Bill
Clinton gave speeches including the
State of the Union address
calling illegal immigration a danger to
the middle class because it was
demonstrably try saying that now at a
democratic fundraiser dinner you'd be
dragged off the stage and charged with
bigotry Democrats are now affirmative ly
in favor of illegal immigration not an
overstatement they tried to shut down
the government on behalf of illegal
aliens they claimed that immigration was
that Congress passed with their support
are now illegitimate and that the
officers charged with enforcing those
laws are fascists and of course they've
made all rational conversation
impossible by framing the entire issue
is a battle in some sort of larger race
war it's shocking but that's not an
exaggeration watch this the Attorney
General is trying to distract the
American people from a failed
immigration system by painting a racist
broad brush of our immigrant community
as dangerous criminals the racist who
are driving immigration policy in the
White House are defining the agenda for
every House Republican and are shaping
the brand of the Republican Party not
just as the party who doesn't want poor
or Latin American immigrants but doesn't
want brown or black or anyone who isn't
white in this country since last night
the president put forth a plan that plan
is a campaign to make America white
again the plan she's talking about of
course would have admitted three million
non-white immigrants talk about
demagoguery Democrats aren't simply the
pro-immigration party they're not the
anti border party the party opposed to
citizenship itself they don't want the
border secured they oppose the
deportation of
anyone under any circumstances even
after criminal offenses they push to
give illegal immigrants welfare benefits
driver's licenses in state tuition
state-funded attorneys to fight American
immigration law they think King
Stanley's killer has more rights than
you do when you confront them on any of
this they say that American citizens
just aren't impressive enough they're
too fat too lazy too addicted to drugs
they demand decent wages they insist on
constitutional rights like I don't know
freedom of speech the right to bear arms
all very any convenient some of them
said that out loud Bill Kristol
basically said that out loud Democratic
leaders would like to see these people
replaced by compliant foreigners who
will serve the ruling class without
complaint well do voters actually
support any of that well actually they
don't but it doesn't matter Democrats
know if they imported enough new voters
they'll be able to run the country
forever would you want to live in that
country probably not but judge for
yourself California Democratic senator
qumola Harris recently told the rest of
us that California her state is our
future listen these folks are really
mired in in rolling back the clock in
time and that's not going to happen
California represents the future and and
they don't like it but there you go yeah
they don't like it but California is our
future says future presidential
candidate Kamla Harris what would that
mean actually if the future were
California well California has more
poverty than any state it is the highest
number of residents don't speak English
at home according to US news it has the
lowest quality of life in the entire
country 50 out of 50 states housing
prices are totally out of control
homelessness is overwhelming go there
and see for yourselves hypodermic
needles literally piling up in the
street the middle class can't flee fast
enough in the past decade a million more
people have moved out of California than
have moved in a u-haul from San Jose to
Phoenix costs 10 times as much as you
all going the either other way because
no one's going the other way this is the
future the camel Harris is boasting
about all this could soon by the way be
a political problem for Democrats the
midterms are coming up this fall
Democrats are gonna win seats for sure
the out party always does Republicans
have made some really dumb mistakes
they're going to win seats the question
is will they retake Congress according
to all predictions they should
definitely promised their voters they're
going to retake Congress and yet in
spite of all these advantages they may
not they may fall short why because
their positions and immigration are
radical and crazy and they have no
popular support in a democracy popular
support still matters
Brian Dean Wright is a Democrat he's
also a former CIA operative who says the
open borders agenda is not sustainable
virtuous as it may be and he joins us
tonight so Brian what do you mean by
that why is it not why is it not
sustainable to let every poor person in
the world move here well here's a bottom
line this argument this debate has
really focused on the past how have
passed immigrants made America's
greatness and indeed they have we all
have connections to agree that the
fantastic immigrant communities right so
what's happening now and in the next 15
to 20 years and what we're seeing is
something not related or connected to
politics but actually technology and
what is happening robotics automation
and machine learning is it's really
effectively making human labor less and
less important and relevant and that's
especially true for jobs that immigrants
hold and oh by the way blue-collar folks
and people of color in in inner cities
in particular exactly so the Obama
administration came out with this study
in late 2016 right before they left and
they said look we're on the verge of
losing jobs if you have them under 20
bucks an hour you are likely and I'm
gonna quote going to be optimator Din to
obsolescence basically your jobs gonna
go away and they said if you're in less
than 20 bucks an hour you know you can
forget about any kind of quality of life
right so these are the kinds of jobs
that immigrants take so we need to be
talking about how this technology is
going to impact not only people here but
the future kinds of people that we
should be embracing as they come into
this country to include a merit-based
system
look everybody can have a different
paint on whether or not we should be
doing this but we should be talking
about what's driving this change and
that changes technology I mean previous
waves of immigration began at the start
of the Industrial Revolution were at the
end of it so it's a totally different
country with different economic needs
what you just said I'm gonna print out
and put at the top of my list of things
to worry about the jobs that previous
generations of immigrants held are going
to be gone so this
so obvious it should be particularly
obvious to people in California which is
leading the technological change why
does nobody say that ever it's
incredibly frustrating anything for
those of us who have been looking at
this issue very very closely so I work
with an organization now or collaborate
with an innovation collective that is
trying to figure out how do you take
care of the people who are already here
Riaan spire re-engaged in particularly
in a flyover States which is an
offensive term but we've embraced it I
like fine let's do this how do we fix
this country in this economy so that
they win all right
absent that who is going to take care of
the folks who are already here never
little a turn you know irrespective of
the folks that we would be importing
down the road how are we gonna pay for
the trillion-dollar programs to take
care of the people who are already here
let alone bringing in new folks at which
about 60% don't have any kind of notable
skills how are we going to take care of
them if ultimately they're not providing
a lot back into the economy and so I
think for the next five to ten years we
have got to be focused on where these
technologies are headed and by the way
I've been slammed by folks on the Left
including Media Matters and others for
even bringing this subject up so it does
really bode well for having this
conversation no it doesn't anybody wants
to be if anyone wants to be angry about
this reach out to people in San
Francisco and Los Angeles and New York
and Boston who are creating this
technology to your point and we get
angry at them for creating a system
where we're gonna have to be more
thoughtful about who we take in this
country yes that's and we are angry by
the way it's only to say it's thrilling
to hear somebody say something that is
demonstrably true that everyone else is
afraid to say and you just did it and
I'm grateful that you did Thank You
Bryan you bet you